[Music]
in invasion of privacy news [ __ ]
where does that smell the time
oh yeah innovate that was private
privacy no girl I made those fried ins
submitted by mad love to the JK crew I
love my friend
there's no backlash towards oh there's
now backlash towards there's now
backlash towards the couple who shared a
viral story of strangers meeting on the
plane the very beginning everyone was
like that so sweet that's so awesome
that's so cool and I started seeing
people tweeting about hey you know
there's no privacy anymore cuz if that
was me I wouldn't want you to do that
about me no yeah so this story here is
about this couple named Rosie and
Houston so they both were uploading on
their IG story like they were unfolding
a love story between these two strangers
on the airplane so it all started with
this one tweet it says bye Rosie last
night on a flight home my boyfriend and
I asked a woman to switch seats with me
so we could sit together we made a joke
that maybe her new seat partner would be
the love of her life and well now I
present you with this thread and then
it's gonna be a whole bunch of photos of
her story so this is how it begins guess
what they have been talking nonstop
since we took off they're both personal
trainers they have touched arms a few
times they are both vegetarians so she
just starts like unfolding like they're
pretty much like their whole life story
for all these strategies here oh its
loudest
she's [ __ ] like this yes the chair
then it says no wedding rings in sight
she pretty but she like blurs out of
face that's very nice it's her and then
he hunky you blurred out face yes and
then we excited I've heard her husband
or boyfriend still and she went into the
bathroom with her ponytail up and came
back with her hair down now she's asking
for some fitness tips so much closer and
it's like their arms it can also just be
economy where the closer matter what
yeah cuz I'm close to everybody yeah
things like they read so much into it it
could just been two strangers just
having small talk or whatever true after
I switched spots with her I literally
said to my boyfriend I hope she meets
the love of her life and the hunky dude
walks over and we freaked out he used to
be a pro soccer player well it's like
damn she's listening really close is
hard to hear conversation on a plane is
so loud so that mean her ears right here
and they're like you'll can you back the
[ __ ] up please
or they're loud as [ __ ] oh yeah
definitely heard people talking on the
black before just to let you know yeah
they're sharing a menu they're getting
closer
this is my mom oh my god your mom was so
hot so friendly they're showing each
other family photos she took his phone
y'all what what what this confident
queen that that word and then she says
yeah important detail this plane has no
AC the flight attendants keep handing
handing out water chicken all right but
the engines are really though
yeah there's a mom yeah but without the
a thing probably lead you to hear a
little bit yeah so then she's like why
would you sit so close to your partner
seat partner yes freaking they just left
for the bathroom at the same time my hot
club back from bathroom together now
both cleaning up trash and helping each
other clean their space she did this put
her head on his shoulder for like a
second
they just started talking about what
they want out of life marriage kids etc
he says he's been too dedicated to his
fitness to pursue relationships that's
all I've got now they're talking so
quietly that's pretty deep though to
talk on someone with on the plane with
like about like your future and marriage
and yeah no I mean in the end they did
follow each other on Instagram so they
say that's the back the juicy part yeah
and it's a like they ended up she took a
photo of them and then when they were
leaving together and [ __ ] anything so
much yeah it's a lot so then this is
where she finishes off okay we've got
follow-up to these people we have found
their instagrams
he found their Instagram they're
following each other and we've got
updates like juicy update
she's a world traveler very sweet girl
single both of them are single they both
appear to be pasted right here in taxes
they're really good you too uh yeah but
I'm sure you you guys are sneaky I think
so yes
so after this whole thing went viral
initially everyone was following the
story like oh my god Oh wonderful plane
Bay and catching flights and feelings I
catch tagged all these things and then
uh and then after like the guy comes out
he starts getting interviews with places
and she was like loving the fame so is
this couple but the woman involved in
this whole story she's been I miss lady
yeah she's been trying to like remain
you know private she doesn't want any of
this attention yeah I think the same
thing dude I was like sparks flew
incorrectly that's what happened and lit
the plane on fire yeah yeah I got to the
point where people like the internet
obviously found her social media stuff
and started harassing her to the point
where now she apparently deleted all of
her social media and so now this story
changed into like man this is [ __ ]
creepy like they should have never been
especially encouraging the people that
were following the story to find her
with both of their names I like in the
beginning when they're scratching their
faces out like you're just telling the
story but then later on the daylight go
we found their Facebook this is what it
is look below it's a good question I'm
not sure like they were they're
basically saying well you guys are
sneaky you can figure it out but like
it's not that hard to figure out who it
is like if if they started following
them on Instagram they found their
Instagram and they don't even know who
they are yeah
you know and then so like it's not that
hard to really figure out and then you
could you could look at flight details
whatever that that flight was yeah and
then if you look closely to the seats
you could kind of figure out who is
sitting aware if you know the couple's
name the the these influencers if you
know their name and you just figure out
who's sat in front of them then you can
figure out the full names of the person
no but that's that's what I mean like
it's not it's not hard if you did a lot
easier than that though because the dude
he ended up seeing this story retweeted
is saying oh well I knew you were taking
pictures so you could find him cuz he
did that was pretty good that [ __ ] all
made sense because the guy did do all
that but then he also uploaded this
video so they didn't know anything about
the girl
until he uploaded this video so this is
the soccer player guy yeah a
good-looking guy I would definitely do
dirty things to him if I was a [ __ ]
yeah all this money to also say thank
you to everyone for respecting helens
privacy the human journey so still out
to take on board in such a short period
of time and yeah could be pretty
overwhelming but just be super
supportive and yeah thank you guys thank
you guys for not respecting Helen Keller
known at all okay Helen Keller from
Dallas Texas hello kitty
five five three I didn't hear a damn
word he was saying he's so fun would you
say yeah so now he's like on Good
Morning America he's like she wants to
be clean babe
no yeah I mean he's like you finally
getting so much who's her he's like he
already had a lot but now from this fame
they just increased his amount so he's
like give it to me baby they're not even
getting together right
I don't know I was I wouldn't be ashamed
to go there but you're not Helen so shut
the [ __ ] up yeah and now that girl that
Rosie she's just getting a lot she's
just like you're disgusting how are you
gonna be so wish you looks no living
privacy there are they just you two like
what are they they do something right
well from what I read it barely she's a
comedian
like a youtuber yeah she was like
tweeting out a BuzzFeed like hey do you
guys have any openings I'd love to be a
journalist and so people are taking that
too like oh you're so gross now you're
taking other people's story and like
China like yeah I just think it was
something that was done on impulse not
meant to she probably didn't think it
was gonna go worldwide you know like the
ways the way that she did that it seemed
like I was if I would do something like
that for you guys like a small group of
friends good now she thought it was just
gonna be her father yeah yeah so then
now she's posted this like lengthy thing
about how she's a really sad how this
just kind of backfire that she hasn't
earned anything off of it she doesn't
wish to that she just it kind of sucks
that the public even cares so much it's
like yeah she kind of invaded someone
else's privacy but why do you care and
why are you invading her privacy now
like it's just yeah like yeah you're
like you're young you're doing the exact
same thing you're getting mad at them
for like gee [ __ ] up
leave it be don't give it attention and
it will just control and contain itself
yeah a lot of for the people that were
initially for this whole story they
ended up tweeting back and saying like
ah man now that I'm thinking about it
now I feel bad that I shared this and
now I'm part of the invasion of privacy
thing and so like they're going back on
their own thing but still condemning her
for it though yeah I think I just think
people made a way better deal than it is
okay it's just when I when I read into
like why people thought a certain way
because there's actually a lot of like
our friends and influencers that are not
so happy with this is because they feel
like there's nowhere now where people
can have privacy or can have an intimate
moment with someone or do something and
then this just felt like creepy to a lot
of people it's all perspective right
like it's but it I guess the fact that
the girl didn't consent is what makes it
not all right I think this is the
reality of the world back in the day
it's like like let's say just even ten
years ago maybe if you go to Disneyland
and then someone requires you you're
like hey what the [ __ ] oh yeah then you
make them put their phone away or
whatever right because there's one
person but now when you go to Disneyland
it's literally like 90 people all
recording themselves on their story so
you don't even know if people recording
you or people recording themselves
there's just so much footage being
uploaded that I don't think I think the
minute you go outside of your door
you're your privacy is gone there's no
such thing as a public private it sucks
it really sucks but I think that's just
kind of a time that we're in now and
international TV and if you do so happen
to feel like someone's doing that to you
then I think you should you have every
single right to be like go don't point
your camera at me or tell them something
like I've had to say stuff like that um
but yeah I think I think that's just the
time we're in now words like you're kind
of susceptible to being exposed like I'm
just [ __ ] now it's like something
happens everyone pulls out your phone so
you have to go hey you nine people don't
film me for us before what it's been one
person to have I'm just trying to be
famous like come on man more pictures
right here I'm about to get a photo my
girlfriend everyone filled it but they
can go viral
[Music]
[Music]